hey guys if you love coffee then you're
gonna love this video but if you're not
a fan of coffee then you probably will
be if you watch this video because in
this video I'm gonna share with you five
ways of how coffee will change your life
let's get to it make you strong now just
very quick if it's your first time here
on my channel I'm Daniel and welcome to
DL m-model
lifestyle subscribe and also click that
notification button so you won't miss
any of the next videos now most of you
know that I love calm because every time
when I make videos and I talk of you
guys I love to have a cup of coffee with
you guys and if you love coffee you
probably already know the type of coffee
you like how to make it so that it
tastes just right but very few people
really understand the bigger picture of
how coffee really affects us and how we
can use it for our benefit to improve
our lives so let's start with the first
one
Coffee improves your brain function now
it's not magically going to increase
your IQ but it helps your brain to be
more efficient so it increases your
focus your reaction time attention
memory and logical reasoning so next
time when your brain feels exhausted
just get some good quality
[Music]
Coffee can help you to live longer
yeah that sounds a little bit strange
but it is true if you drink coffee a
healthy way without adding those there's
extra unhealthy stuff like sugar and
cream then coffee is actually super
healthy if you drink it the right way
it's a lot of studies on this but it
shows that drinking coffee on a daily
basis is directly linked to a longer
life one study for example shows us that
if you drink around 1 to 2 cups a day it
decreases your risk of type 2 diabetes
Coffee helps with depression or negative
moods it's a lot of studies on this and
it shows that coffee is directly linked
to how we feel to our mood how does it
influence us well we feel more positive
one study for example was done over a
period of ten years and it's ested
people who drank coffee with caffeine
and people who drank coffee with no
caffeine and the people who drank
between two to three cups of coffee
normal coffee with caffeine had a
decreased risk of developing depression
while those people who drank coffee that
decaf had no change at all a lot of
you're gonna like this one
but coffee can help you to lose weight
how does it do that well coffee
increases your metabolism and for around
3 out of every 10 people it's even
stronger more like a laxative but don't
add that unhealthy sugar and cream if
you want to lose weight
now it's very interesting that coffee
gives you a lot of energy most if you
already know this but it also makes you
feel relaxed at the same time it's true
so how is that possible
well the caffeine from coffee goes into
your bloodstream very fast and gives you
that boost of energy which you have for
the next ten minutes to one hour or even
more so how can you then also make you
feel relaxed
well caffeine doesn't just boost your
alertness but it makes you more relaxed
and calm by increasing your brains
dopamine and glutamine now if you're new
to the coffee world you need to know
that is a lot more flavors an
interesting coffees out there in the
world that you know about and they all
taste different and then when you roast
them in different ways it changes the
flavor even more and then the method you
choose to make your coffee changes the
flavor even more the coffee world is
huge and the more you start to learn
about this the more you start to love
and appreciate coffee even more a lot of
my top picks of coffee and also coffee
equipment for you in a video description
down below so you can check it out
cheers guys
[Music]
Oh
[Music]